just in order to get some more
familiarity with joint PDFs let us look
at independent normals actually this is
an important example because noise is
often modeled by normal random variables
and noise terms that show up at
different parts of a system or at
different times are often assumed to be
independent suppose that we have two
standard normal random variables X and Y
with zero means and unit variances if
they're independent their joint PDF is
the product of the marginal PDFs and
takes this form this is just what the
PDF of a standard normal X and the PDF
of a standard normal Y and we multiply
them if we are to plot this joint PDF we
obtain this figure it looks like a bell
which is centered at the origin at the
point with coordinates 0 0 one way to
think about what is going on here is to
rewrite this expression as 1 over 2 pi
and then the exponential of minus 1/2 x
squared plus y squared if we look at the
unit circle in XY space which is the set
of points at which X square plus y
squared is equal to 1 then on that
circle the PDF takes a constant value
because this quantity is constant on
that circle and the same is true for any
other circle on any circle the PDF takes
a constant value of course a different
constant so the circles centered at the
origin are the so-called contours of the
joint PDF on each contour the joint PDF
is a constant let us now generalize
consider two independent normal random
variables but with general means mu X
and mu Y and variances Sigma x squared
and Sigma Y squared
the joint is again the product of the
marginal PDFs and therefore takes this
form this looks intimidating but in fact
it is pretty simple this part is just a
normalizing constant it's a constant
that's needed so that the joint PDF
integrates to 1 what we have here is the
negative exponential of a quadratic
function of x and y let us plot the
contours of this quadratic remember that
the contour is the set of points where
the quadratic takes a constant value and
by consequence the joint PDF also takes
a constant value if you set this
quadratic to a constant what you have is
the equation that describes an ellipse
and it is an ellipse whose principal
axes run along the x and y directions
and those ellipses are all centered at
this particular point mu X mu Y the
joint PDF is largest when the exponent
is equal to 0 and this happens when X is
equal to MU X and Y is equal to MU Y
that is right at the center of the
ellipse that's where the joint PDF is
largest as you move to ellipses that are
further out on this outer ellipse this
expression is a constant it's the
exponential of the negative of some
positive numbers so you get a smaller
value for the joint PDF if you move to a
further ellipse further out
then again the joint PDF will be a
constant but it's going to be a smaller
constant now for the case of standard
normals the joint PDF was circularly
symmetric the contours were actually
circles instead of ellipses but this is
not the case in general for example
suppose that the variance of Y is bigger
than the variance of X then you get a
shape as the one shown in this figure
since the variance of Y is larger we
expect Y to take values over a
reigns and to be larger typically than
the values of X and so the bell shape
that we have for the joint PDF is
stretched in the y direction it extends
further out in the y direction than it
does in the x direction
to conclude the joint PDF of two
independent normals has the shape of a
bell the center of the bell is
determined by the means furthermore the
Bell is stretched in the x and y
directions by an amount that is
determined by the variances of x and y
however the stretching is always along
the coordinate axis if you wanted a bell
that stretches in some diagonal
direction or if you have contours that
are ellipses but with some different
kinds of axes then you will have
dependence between the two random
variables in that case we will be
dealing with a so-called bivariate
normal distribution but we will not
pursue this any further
at this point